[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARUN ANANTHAMPALAYAM:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Cloud on Air Live
Webinar from Google Cloud.
We are hosting Cloud On
Air Webinar every Tuesday.
My name is Arun Ananthampalayam,
Product Marketing Manager
for IoT.
And today we will be
talking about building
predictive maintenance
solution using machine
learning with Google Cloud.
You can ask questions
any time on the platform.
And we have Google on standby
to try to answer them.
I'd start by giving you a
quick overview on Google Cloud
Platform, and then go
in depth into Cloud IoT
Services for developers
and business leaders.
We will also talk about
existing IoT apps and services
that you're building
on top of GCP
as well as all the
rich capabilities
that you can take
advantage of today.
We've also planned a predictive
maintenance live demo.
So without wasting time,
let's jump right in.
So what is Google Cloud
Platform or in short, GCP?
GCP is a suite of cloud
computing services
that runs from the same
infrastructure as our consumer
products such as Gmail,
Google Search, YouTube,
and so on and so forth.
As a matter of fact, we
have over seven products
that has more than one
billion active users.
If we look at it from an
enterprise customer's point
of view, currently they serve
over one billion end users
each day.
We are operating at
a very high scale.
And this is relative to
other cloud providers
as you can tell.
We spent over $30 billion
in the last three years
on infrastructure,
making Google Cloud
one of the largest
investor and computing
infrastructures in the planet.
And we are committed to offering
a wide range of IoT services
and solutions, both
for cloud and also
for Edge across industries.
Google Cloud has been
named as a leader
in Insight PaaS, which is
platform as a service category.
We believe this recognition
reflects our commitment
to building a better
cloud, the one that
lets you innovate freely, build
and deliver great products
and services faster
to your end customers.
And we cannot talk about cloud
services without addressing
the back end infrastructure.
Do you know that
we own and operate
one of the largest backbone
networks in the world,
connecting our data centers
with hundreds of thousands
of miles of fiber optics cables?
Our network can deliver low
latency, very high throughput,
of course, with high security.
Once the customer's
traffic is on our network,
it's no longer transmitting
the public internet,
making it less likely to
be attacked, intercepted,
or manipulated.
According to one
estimate from Gartner,
it says about 10 billion of
so-called connected things
will be used in 2018, up 27%
year over year, give or take.
And it's projected to reach
about $20 billion by 2020.
These devices are generating
tons of data, as you know.
And Google has been
in the forefront
of addressing big data
challenges at scale for over 18
years.
Now we are making
these technologies
available for our end
customers, our GCP customers,
so they can accelerate the
business transformation.
It's that simple.
Our platform is now enabling
customers like Schlumberger
in oil and gas, Oden
Technologies, Smart Parking,
Cognite to cut cost and
complexity while building
their IoT solutions.
We will dive deep into
some of the customer
examples in a moment.
On top of the best
infrastructure,
we have built a comprehensive
set of compute, storage,
database, data analytics,
and machine learning
services for our customers now.
We now offer server-less fully
managed petabyte scale platform
which acts as the foundation
for machine learning and data
analytics.
As you can see on
the screen, we have
end to end services from capture
all the way to dashboarding
for IoT use cases.
Now you can use scalable
machine learning services
to move beyond simple
data analytics.
And this is to attain
actionable insights even faster.
And we have developed
reference architectures
for some of the common use
cases, like, for example,
predictive maintenance,
asset tracking.
This is with complete
documentation,
so you can quickly go from
POCs to implementation
in fairly short timeframe.
Now pulling all these big
data technologies together
and looking at four
key pillars, you
can see that Google Cloud
has wide range of services
to enable business
transformation.
This is across enterprise.
So services like
Cloud IoT, which
is a fully managed service,
allows you to securely connect,
manage, and ingest
data from millions
of globally dispersed devices.
So the devices could be
located anywhere in the globe,
would be able to connect to
it with a single endpoint.
In combination
with other services
that Google Cloud has to
offer, we can actually
tell the entire story.
So you can collect, process,
analyze, and visualize
IoT data in both real
time and also at rest.
I'd give you a
high level overview
on some of these
services before we
dive into the predictive
maintenance architecture.
So it'll give you some context
around what I'm talking about.
The first one is
the Cloud Pub/Sub.
It's publisher subscriber that
you're very much use to, MQDT.
The service that we offer
delivers low latency
and durable messaging.
It connects services located
anywhere in the world
and offers easy to
use REST JSON APIs.
Fairly simple.
BigQuery is another service
that I want to point out.
It's our answer to enterprise
data warehousing solution.
It is server-less,
highly scalable,
low cost data housing solution
offered by Google Cloud.
It is designed to make all
your data analytics fast
and effective.
BigQuery also allows you to
analyze what's happening now
by making your latest
process, asset,
and business data immediately
available for analytics.
So it's all real time.
So the next one that
I want to talk about
is the data flow,
the cloud data flow.
So you can build the fully
managed data pipelines
and also do ETL
transformations using Dataflow.
We also have a product
called Dataproc,
which is nothing but a fully
managed Hadoop and Spark.
So you can also utilize that.
So if you're coming from
an Hadoop or Spark world,
we would definitely
recommend the Dataproc.
Or if you're building
something from scratch,
then Dataflow is the way to go.
Last but not least, starting
from right to left--
I'll start with the Cloud
Machine Learning Engine first.
The Cloud ML Engine is
also a managed service
that enables developers
and data scientist
to build superior
machine learning models
and to deploy into production.
We also offer AutoML.
So with the limited
machine learning expertise,
one can train high
quality models.
So you don't have to
start from scratch.
You can take one of the
pre-built models that's
available open source.
And Google has committed to open
sourcing some of these models
already.
So I think we have
1,400 comments in GitHub
already on that.
And this is something
that you can leverage.
And Google as something called
transfer learning technology.
So you can apply
that to build models.
We also offer out of the
box machine learning APIs.
For example, vision
API, translation API,
video intelligence API to take
advantage of machine learning.
So now that you're familiar with
Google Cloud Platform and some
of the differentiated
services that we offer,
we can look at general
architecture for an IoT use
case and how you can stitch
these different services
to developer together to
develop a scalable application.
Over here, device data is
ingested using IoT services.
The IoT core is
responsible for secure
device management and
also device onboarding.
Followed by Cloud Pub/Sub,
on the other hand,
this service can handle
incoming device data at scale.
And also the downstream
services can consume this data
from Pub/Sub by subscribing
to a certain topic.
So one of them is
a cloud function.
I want to spend a
couple of minutes
talking about cloud function.
One, it's no service to
prohibition manage or patch
when it comes to
cloud functions.
It simply runs the code.
And you pay for only
the time the code runs.
And it's fully managed.
So for the even data that
it receives from the Cloud
Pub/Sub, it can quickly
perform a data processing task
or a file processing
task, if the file
is coming from the IoT core.
And it can handle the
output back to IoT core
or to other services.
This is without spinning
up virtual machines.
It's a highly
differentiated service
when compared to
other providers.
And I would encourage you
to definitely try that out.
And the data flow,
once it gets the data
from either cloud
function or Pub/Sub,
it can do ETL on the data.
And it can either store it
on a Bigtable or BigQuery.
This is for doing
real time analytics.
You can use products
like Datalab.
Or even you can do machine
learning on the data that's
on the BigQuery.
And like we talked
about, machine learning,
we have multiple services.
If you're starting from
scratch, then ML Engine
is the way to go.
But if you have a bunch
of data, and if you
wanted to take the existing
model and kind of train
it to make it better, than
auto ML is the way to go.
Finally, if you're looking to
build an informative dashboard,
then you can use Data
Studio Services to do that.
We've built end to end platform.
This is packed with
rich capabilities
for all kinds of IoT use
cases, as you can tell.
So the analytics workload
falls into four categories--
descriptive,
diagnostic analytics,
predictive analytics,
and prescriptive.
So if you look at
the descriptive
and the diagnostic analytics,
a lot of BI tools and reporting
tools can do that right now.
For the predictive analytics
and the prescriptive analytics,
you need to do some sort
of a machine learning.
That's what we're going to
talk about in the coming slide.
So let's first talk about the
predictive maintenance, which
is a version of
predictive analytics.
So as you very well understand,
the unpredictable downtime
or unplanned downtime,
it's commonly referred to,
this is in production
environment,
can cost millions of
dollars of losses,
and as well as environmental
damage and even life hazards.
So you know you can make your
manufacturing, maintenance
department, and
operation teams more
productive with
predictive maintenance.
But how would you accelerate
building high quality
predictive maintenance
application
for your enterprise?
And also if you're an
independent software vendor,
which is ISVs, how will you
develop predictive maintenance
solution for different
assets across industries?
These are challenging problems.
So we've developed an
end to end platform
to address that challenge.
Imagine if you can build
a solution from scratch,
which automatically predicts
when the equipment needs
maintenance?
It's just amazing.
And if you can do it in a matter
of weeks, that's even better.
So to build and deploy a
machine learning model,
you'll be following six steps.
You start with
collecting information
from different departments.
And also once you understand
the exact business problem,
you can gather enough
hypotheses as well.
So once you acquire
all the data,
including the device
data, telemetry data,
data from manufacturers,
could be FMEA,
and so on and so forth, then
you can identify the best model.
There are multiple
models out there.
There are RNNs, CNNs, recurrent
neural network models,
there are convolutional
neural networks model.
And that are also specific
model like the LSTMs.
So you can pick and
choose the model that's
applicable for your
use case and then train
the model using the
ML Engine servers
that we have with the data
that you've already acquired.
The data could be stored
in cloud storage, BigQuery,
you name it.
And once you train
that model, then you
can decide on whether to
deploy it in the cloud
or with Edge, based
on the use case.
So now most of the predictive
maintenance solution
that I've seen, my
experience, what it does
is it takes few historic
pattern and uses
one dimensional pattern
matching algorithms to predict
the failure of an asset,
which is not really accurate
and can be unreliable
in many instances.
The solution that we propose
is true predictive maintenance.
Both the end user and also the
independent software vendor
can develop ML models from
scratch, or taking something
and amplifying the accuracy
for some of those models.
This is for any
asset that they have.
And they can
incorporate this model
into their on-prem application.
Or if the app lies outside of
the firewall, in many cases,
especially in
factories, then you
can do callbacks to the
server to get new models.
So if it's within the
firewall, then the model
has to be on a gateway
device or some sort of device
right next to the asset.
But if there is an
opportunity to put the model
outside of the firewall, then
you have a little more freedom
to go back and forth, do
callbacks to the cloud.
So in this case, we
used a specific kind
of RNN, which stands for
Recurrent Neural Network called
LSTM, which is Long
Short-Term Memory.
That's what it stands for.
That's the model
that we started with.
And then we've built a
predictive maintenance
for this particular
application, which I'm
going to demo in a few seconds.
And so once you build the
model, then it's followed--
evaluating the model.
So use the test data
to test the model.
And the 80/20 rule is that
80% of the data that you've
gathered you can use
to train the model.
And 20% of the data can
be used to test the model.
So once the model is
hypertuned, then it's
ready for deployment
and prediction.
So let me provide
you with some context
before I jump into the demo.
So we're going to
take a real use case
and demonstrate
machine learning.
As you know, a typical oil
rig has about thousands
of sensors and control
system modules,
acquiring telemetry
and process data.
These are complex assets.
And these assets are located
in the middle of nowhere.
And some of these assets, they
don't have good connectivity
to the cloud.
So the models may have
to reside at the Edge.
So as a side note, in
this particular demo,
we're going to assume
that the model is running
right next to the asset itself.
So with that in mind, we can
go and see some of the things
that we have done
on the demo site.
So again, now just
to set the context,
this is an example of
the complexities involved
in capturing and analyzing
data from connected devices.
So let's switch
over to the demo.
There we go.
And again, this is the
fictitious upstream oil and gas
manufacturer.
So here, they have
a bunch of assets.
When you double click on
one of those locations,
as you can tell, there's
multiple sensors on these rigs.
And you can drill into the
specifics of each of those.
So let me switch over
to the demo to show you
exactly what I mean by that.
There we go.
So when you click
one of these sensors,
it'll show you the
telemetry data coming
from those different sensors.
So in this case, the
operational dashboard
reflects the real
time machines data.
So this could be the tension,
the pressure, temperature,
the viscosity of the oil.
And here's a simple architecture
of the predictive maintenance
application itself.
So the data is gathered
from these different rigs.
And Cloud IoT Core publishes
the data to Cloud Pub/Sub.
So once the machine data has
been gathered through a gateway
device, it gets published
to the Cloud Pub/Sub.
And Google IoT Core,
once it receives it--
of course, with the time stamp--
it publishes to the Pub/Sub.
And from there, the data flows
to the data flow as an event.
And we make DNN regular serve
Cloud ML call from the data
flow.
And again, the data is posted
on the BigQuery in parallel.
And also the data
is sent in real time
to the Cloud ML Engine.
So the predictive
maintenance model
is being built in real time.
Then once it's
built, then you can
deploy it, and start predicting
right then and there.
So once you deploy the model,
once you start the prediction,
either you can write it
to a BigQuery itself,
or otherwise, you can show it
in real time on a visualization
engine.
So this is a very
simple architecture
of predictive maintenance.
So this is a bunch
of sensor data.
So we are monitoring the device
health with incoming time
series data here.
And we can also easily
and accurately determine
the predictive remaining life.
So if we go back to the
previous slide, the red bar
that you see, it
shows exactly what's
the predicted cycle remaining.
In this case, zero, which means
that the asset is failing.
So you can actually
get this in real time.
So let's say that if a
predictive lifetime of an asset
is 172 days, then you know that
within 172 days, plus or minus
whatever their rate is,
the asset will fail.
So you can plan a planned
down time, rather than
an unplanned downtime,
which costs millions
and millions of dollars.
So the predictive accuracy
is very important.
So some of the applications
that I talked about previously,
the predictive applications
that you see in the market, some
of them are not that
accurate, which is not
the way it's supposed to be.
So when you build the model
using the ML Engine, especially
the RNN models that
I was talking about,
you can actually hypertune it
to decrease the error rate.
So when you see that
green line pointing down,
which means the
hypertuning is happening,
and we are increasing the
accuracy of the model.
So let's look at a couple
of customer examples
and see how they are taking
advantage of GCP services
to improve their
operational efficiency.
So Schlumberger is one of them.
And as you know, they're the
leader in providing oil and gas
services.
They use Cloud IoT services like
Cloud IoT Core and other GCP
services to capture a
large amount of data
and do analytics at
a petabyte scale.
The second one that
I want to talk about
is the Oden Technology.
They've built their Oden
factory platform solution
on top of GCP.
And their technology
empowers manufacturers
to eliminate waste and
also increase output.
Oden Technologies, they use
the hardened gateway devices,
battle tested ones.
And what they do
is they retrofit it
in existing industrial
plastic molding machines.
These are legacy machines
with little intelligence.
So they were able to
collect and process and also
analyze to derive insights
from these data that's
gathered from that machine
on a gateway device.
And this is using
the platform module
that they use from GCP services.
So they were able to reduce
the change over time about 33%.
And getting the machines
to an optimal prediction
faster is very, very
difficult. But with the kind
of insights that they
were able to derive,
they were able to
do it quite faster.
And this gave the manufacturer
an additional 3,500 hours
of production every year.
And this is about $1 million
in additional revenue
that they would have lost if
they hadn't done something
like this.
So a little more stats
on Oden Technologies.
The call to action
is I encourage
you to visit our website,
cloud.google.com to sign up
for a free trial today.
And also try out our IoT
services like IoT Core
and so on and so forth.
You can also learn more
about the IoT solutions.
So today I demoed the
predictive maintenance solution.
But we also have asset
tracking, smart cities, and also
we've done some work on the
remote monitoring side as well.
So eventually, these demos
will be posted on our website.
And we are also planning
to make these codes
available through
GitHub fairly soon.
So you can learn a little
bit about the use cases,
and also do a test
drive on our web site.
And I would also recommend
you to look at Android Things.
Android Things is our
operating system for IoT.
So you can actually run
predictive maintenance model
on top of Android Things
using a TensorFlow Lite
Inference on a gateway
device to do prediction.
And this is just one
use case, but you
can do quite number
of things with that.
And also the one takeaway is
in addition to the IoT Core
Service, we have
end to end services,
going from capturing
data to processing,
kind of cleansing the data using
ETL, data flow, or Dataproc.
And then either storing the data
or doing real time analytics
on that.
So you can do stream analytics,
you can do batch analytics.
You can do a number of things.
On top of that, you can
also do machine learning,
kind of going beyond
simple analytics.
And if you're interested
in dashboarding,
also we have tools for that.
So we have built an end to
end platform for all your IoT
use cases.
So I definitely recommend
you to go try it out.
And we're also partnering
with the well-known companies
like Intel Microchip
on a number of fronts.
The one I want to
point out is Microchip.
We've done some work
on the security.
So this is hardware root of
trust is what we call it.
See there is a proprietary
chip that goes on
and microcontroller,
which handles the security
side of things.
So with that, stay tuned for
live Q&A. We will be back
in less than a minute.
Hello, welcome back everyone.
So we have a list of questions.
Let me go through it one by one.
So how does Google
help enterprises
build predictive
maintenance solutions?
How does an enterprise go
from building a POC/pilot
to building a live
production deployment?
It's a good question.
So like I said before,
the best place to start
is once you understand the
business problem very well,
then you need data.
So from my experience
at least, say
I'm putting some context
to this question.
Let's say if it's an oil
refinery or some sort
of a manufacturing plant,
either process or discrete,
it doesn't matter,
most of those datas
are stored in historian on-prem.
Could be a level 2 historian,
a level 3 historian.
In some cases, they do store
it in a private data center.
But the data doesn't
leave the premises.
In those instances,
what I would recommend
is, first, normalize the data.
What I mean by normalizing is
it could be a number of formats.
I hear that there is about
150 protocols out there
like Modbus DMB3,
BACnet, you name it.
So in the batch
processing world at least,
I've seen OPC and OPCU8,
quite famous protocols.
So normalizing it in
one of those formats,
and then taking the normalized
data and cleaning it up--
basically, doing the ETL
transformation on the data.
So for example, you don't
have to send every single bits
and bytes out of the historian.
You normalize doing
average temperature
over a particular window.
Right?
So whatever you can do
to clean up the data,
and then you can
take that clean data
and start doing
machine learning.
So one way to start
machine learning
is, if you're not familiar
with some of these models,
there is hundreds of
thousands of models
already out there open-source.
So of course, Google
has contributed to many
of those models already.
You can go to
TensorFlow or Cafe,
or there are so many
other services out there
where you can take one
of these models that
can do a pretty good
predictive maintenance
and start with that.
Now with the data and
with a decent model,
you can start building.
ML Engine, one of
the Google services,
can be used to actually train
that model, make it better.
And then you have
to make a decision
whether to include that model
as part of an application,
or to have an app,
have a model separate,
and do some sort
of a connection.
So if you have an asset
manager or an asset
predictive
maintenance, if you're
running some sort of an
application like that,
then I would
definitely recommend
that model stays separate
from your application,
because you may
have many assets.
So you can build models
for individual assets--
could be turbines, could
be steam engine or whatnot.
So that's the best
place to start.
And we have end to end
services to do that right now
on Google Cloud.
As a matter of fact,
there's a multiple webinars
that's already been done on
YouTube that you can go take
a look at to start this work.
So good luck with that.
The second question is,
what kind of protocols
does IoT Core support?
So right now, we
support MQDT and HTTP.
But in the future, we
may support protocols
like AMQP and CoApps.
So any device that can
communicate MQDT or HTTP
can connect to IoT Core.
And IoT Core is a
universal endpoint.
So what works, doesn't matter
where your devices are,
could be anywhere
in the world as
long as you can talk
to those protocol,
you can communicate
to Cloud IoT Core.
So can you list some of
the customers or platforms?
Yes, so in my presentation,
I've listed some examples.
Schlumberger is one,
Oden Technologies.
And top of that, we have
FogHorn, which is our partner.
They built that IoT platform
on top of GCP as well.
And we also have our Aila.
They've also recently started
supporting or integrating
their solution with
IoT Core Service.
So your seeing a lot of
IoT platform providers
supporting that.
So what if I don't
have any training data?
Can I gather it in real time?
Yes.
So of course, any time we
talk about machine learning,
clean data and a
lot of data is good.
It's always the case.
But we do have certain
pre-built APIs.
Like, for example, in many
of the industrial use cases
I've seen, the visual
API, that comes in handy.
So it's already pre-built model.
So you can start with maybe
hundreds and thousands
of images.
Let's say that if you
don't have thousands,
you can start with 100 images.
And you can still
train that model
for a certain application.
Let's say that if you want to do
some sort of a thermal imaging
on something and
predict the result,
then you can use a video
intelligence for it.
Of course, we also
have NLP, which
is a natural language
processing API.
Again, if you wanted to
read a bunch of data points,
could be a sentence, or it could
be a Twitter feed or whatnot--
and if you wanted to
derive emotions from that,
you can certainly do that.
So for that, you don't
need a ton of data.
And you can use real time
data that's coming into
to do machine learning on that.
And we also have another
service called AutoML.
So if you're not sure
what model to pick,
you don't have
high quality data,
then AutoML is
another way to go.
So with the limited
data, it can actually
recommend you a
pretty good model
where the accuracy is north of
70% at least in most use cases.
And then you can kind
of hypertune from there.
The next one is,
does Google Cloud
offer out of the box models
for image recognition
and classification?
Yes.
So the visual API that
I was talking about
can be used for image
classification and image
recognition.
And a lot of the industrial
use cases I've seen
have a bunch of labels.
And they wanted
to be able to name
those labels, what those are.
So in those cases again, you can
use the visual API to do that.
And of course, there's
a lot of other use cases
where a pre-built model
will come in handy in those
instances.
You can refer to one
of the pre-built models
that we're already marketing,
or you can actually
find something from the open
source community as well.
And use the ML
Engine or AutoML too
to build and train the model.
So where can I go to try
out the IoT Services?
It's a good question.
So cloud.google.com/iot-core,
that's one of the IoT services
that we have.
And that you can actually
go to cloud.Google.com
to do a free trial.
So on the top right hand corner
you would see a Launch button.
Once you launch, it will ask
you for your Google account.
So if you don't have one,
you can create one there.
And then you can take advantage
of some of the cloud services.
So the next question
is related to pricing.
So we do offer the first
250 MB free per month
for the IoT Core Service.
And we have a very
competitive pricing model
and a simple pricing model
for you to understand.
The next one is, can I
do real time analytics
on telemetry data
received from equipment?
Yes.
So we can do both real time just
streaming analytics and also
batch analytics.
The way we
differentiate is right
now to do those
different things,
you may have to write
additional line of codes,
or you may have to use
different tools altogether.
So in Google Cloud's
case, we have a product
called Data Flow, which
is fully managed service
where you can do
e-tail transformation
and also do analytics using
BigQuery in real time.
And don't have to write
additional line of codes
for streaming analytics
and batch analytics.
And it's fairly easy to
orchestrate a ETL pipeline
and go from there.
So again, there is ton of
documentation resources
out there, both in video format
and also in documentation
format for you to go look at.
So I would highly
recommend looking
at some of the next videos
or the Google IO videos
that we have done on that.
The last question is,
I don't know Python.
Can I do ML in any
other language?
Yes.
So we do support
multiple languages.
We do support R, we
support of course, Python,
and C++ in certain areas.
So there are multiple
ways that you can program
machine learning models.
And I don't know exactly how
many languages we support.
But that is something that
you can refer to our ML Engine
website to gather the details.
Again, the documentation
is pretty good there.
So with that, thank
you for your time.
And the next session
that we have is on AI.
So I highly recommend that you
stick around to watch that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]